okay so next up first afternoon session
we have Eric waken from Columbia
University and he's going to talk about
the community service society
photographs project that he's been
working okay thanks for coming out i'm
going to talk about a collaborative
project that the library did working
with a donor or the community service
society and working with about five
different units within the library to
get a series of 1500 photographs
digitized and publicized and i'll go
into the details of a few things about
how we do it this is my agenda i'll talk
about what i think collaboration means
who the stakeholders are I'll go through
the photographs and why they're
important and I'll take you through the
process we used together to get to the
point where they're now going to be
online soon for users I take
collaboration to be people working
together towards a common goal I know
there's a debate in librarianship about
collaboration between two different
institutions versus collaboration inside
an institution so this is to some extent
probably twenty percent us and community
service society and maybe eighty percent
the units within the library that work
together to get this done that by the
way is shot from the collection that's
called old man's toyshop these are the
stakeholders and i'll talk about them in
a minute so let's talk about what the
photographs are how they got to us
before we get to what we're doing with
them community service society get my
notes up it's about a hundred seventy
years old they're a advocacy direct
service social welfare agency in New
York and not-for-profit in the last
fiscal year they had about 21 million
dollars in expenses most gone out to
serving poor people of color in New York
they were found at 170 years ago in two
different iterations which I'll talk
about in a moment one of the things
they're known for is they effectively
created this notion of social work
Columbia University School of Social
Work is derived from a school of social
work they created and one of the reasons
we have the collection is because we got
many social welfare collections to the
school
of social work which came to the Rare
Book and Manuscript library at Columbia
other things they've done historically
in there earlier iterations are advocate
for tenement housing laws school lunch
programs public health programs they
continue to do that for different
different audiences today these are the
precursor agencies for the community
service society you can see what the
first one is called Association for
improving the condition of the poor and
these photographs in the collection were
all created with the intent of
advocating for poor New Yorkers the
collection itself it's about 300 linear
feet of material in the special
collection of Columbia University that's
everything plus about 1500 photographs I
say about 1500 because we really don't
know exactly how many there are there is
an official count but as we started
digging into it for the project it ended
up creeping up and creeping up and
creeping up I think the official count
was thirteen hundred and eighty six or
1336 and there have been bunches we
found in folders that extend that a
little further out there are also about
43 entities that created them including
some famous names you see Jacob Riis
Lewis Hine and many unfamous names like
Hiram Myers who ends up being a
fantastic photographer I'll talk about
him as well as almost 700 that are
unknown so it's this gigantic body of
work that was a very valuable from the
1880s to the 1930s let me show you some
of them in you tell me that's a pretty
iconic photographs has been used quite a
bit in Social Welfare literature that's
one by Jesse Tarbuck spiels Hiram Myers
I'm going to come back to him in a
moment
jacob riis the glass negatives of the
reefs collection are at the museum of
the city of New York but community
services say society use some of these
images in their literature there are
some illustrations not very many about
30 and there are a lot of street scenes
which allow us to do some geographic
locating so why are they important one
thing you need to know is that to get a
broad-based digital project done in the
Columbia University Libraries you have
to advocate for resources being
allocated to it right I mean the library
has time it has people it has money than
it is not going to give it to us because
we want to do this we have to say this
is important for the library's
objectives for scholarship and for the
larger community and then we put
together a collaborative project on it
so let me tell you how we did that one
of the things is we looked at the
strategic goals for the library and we
said does making this collection widely
accessible makes sense so we did a
little presentation I see it meets these
parts of our strategic goals it will
certainly be easier to find the
digitized photos it will serve an
incredibly broad community of people who
need access to these photographs from
scholars and this kind of social
documentary photography documenting the
condition of the poor is studied across
the board from Social Work to sociology
to history to art history and people are
constantly coming in to use this
collection it's one of our most use
collections and obviously the more it
gets handled the worse it is as a
special collection so one of our
arguments for digitizing it is
preserving it right if it's digitized
less people will be coming and pawing
through it so that's one of the
arguments we made a whole series of
arguments about serving scholarship
describing the collection we're going to
create 30 different metadata categories
for each object so people will know the
date who did it what it was used for and
things like that so we made I think a
pretty effective argument um for the
library we also want to make an argument
I think it's useful for the donor
because they gave us the collection and
they use the collection a lot and if you
look at community service society's
goals today these are their three large
goals and what they call their urban
agenda jobs economic security and health
care and if you look at the things they
do this is a 2011 pamphlet from them
you'll notice
that photo is in the pamphlet now CSS
can come to columbia have its digitize a
photo as a tiff and send it to them and
use it but i'm having them all available
is useful this is also a moment where i
want to acknowledge as a historian
because i'm historian also that there is
a whole discourse around the
advisability and the in advisability of
using pictures of poor children to
advocate for poor children right so the
whole discourse among historians and
sociologists and art historians but how
problematic and an unfortunate that is
and exploitive but among social workers
and other people they say we like to use
these photos because we are providing
direct service to the poor and it
motivates people to give money to
programs to help the poor if you know
the New York Times neediest cases fund
community service society is one of the
top seven recipients and donors of money
from them so from a library perspect
from an intellectual perspective we had
a conference around this whole issue and
it was wonderful but from the library's
perspective we want to make this
material available and our patrons can
use it as they see fit to criticize the
notion of this kind of social
documentary photography or to use it for
other purposes but our goal is to make
it widely available so let me talk about
the process this is another man from the
old man's toyshop community service
society has approached us over a number
of years to talk about the collection
how they could use the collection how
would serve their needs and so we
started having this conversation among
us about isn't it interesting there's a
donor that gave us this collection it's
widely used it would be widely used more
if we're digitized it serves their needs
would serve our needs and it all came
together that we decided to to go
forward with the project we scoped it
out try to count the number of items um
determine the existing metadata what we
had typed up in our finding Aid and
elsewhere and then what kind of metadata
we would have to create copyrights that
bugbear of libraries can cruise is not
here oh my god
I'm gonna give you some so this is a big
issue right we're talking about um um
making this material broadly available
on the web so the copyright issues of 43
different named entities and one unknown
is an issue for us how we got to that
point was with Kenny's help I want to
talk to them before we could get the
project approved as a collaborative
project we had to start working with
Kenny to figure this out conservation
wiki and workflow I'll talk about in a
minute so I am NOT a copyright attorney
but I learned a hell of a lot from Kenny
about how to think about this material
what pre-1920 3 is in the public domain
what is not in the public domain there
was a whole host of research done in
1991 before the web was a really useful
tool for research about copyright issues
and what we found out was the vast
majority of objects are in the public
domain because of publication and those
that weren't were created as what's
called work for hire for the community
service society that means they paid
people to go and take the pictures to
use in their publications to advocate
for the poor that's incredibly important
for libraries because that means that
the community service society can give
us the right to use the more at least
not dis acknowledge that we think their
rights works for hire so with those two
hurdles out of the way most of them in
the public domain the rest are works for
hire community service society said yeah
please go ahead and do this we support
it fully um and we got to that point I
want to show you something if you've
seen this yeah this is pretty
interesting I teach a course in echo
memory and narrative or students use
primary source collections I tell them
to use various genealogical databases so
one of the ways again I'm not advising
who's a lawyer just them just a
historian that I'm we look at figuring
out work for hires who did the
photograph in who they were so on
ancestry.com is Hiram Myers his draft
card from 1917 Hiram ours the
photographer did some was early
photographs two things I point out
there's arrow for his name this is his
occupation social worker this is where
he worked Association from proving the
condition of the poor it doesn't prove
anything but it builds a case that these
people who took the photographs in some
cases were employed by the entity that
asked them to take the photographs it
builds a case for work for hire and just
stumbled across it because a researcher
from
Spain came in when she was saying I saw
all these wonderful photographs by this
guy Hiram Myers no one knows who he is
it's true you go to eastman house they
have no idea who he is so are you going
to ancestry.com of course they digitize
everything in the world you type his
name and boom his draft card is up there
so it's a useful tool in many ways we
could probably do it for some of the
other photographers in there but I
haven't done it okay I'll talk about the
workflow a bit my colleagues told me to
keep it high level not bore you to death
we match the photographs with existing
metadata we transcribe it into an
interface that i'm going to show you
which is really unique and interesting
we ran it by conservation to check out
which photographs need conservation
access we scan the photographs we the
library's our collaborative effort we
scan these typed information sheets that
the community service society 20 30 40
years ago typed up to go with many of
the photographs OCR those and put that
in the database um expert metadata
people created structured metadata
around the data we didn't have it they
figured out from the photos we did
quality control we are rehousing all the
material now in the archive so people
can still use it at least each
photograph will get its own little
sleeve and folder and then we're going
to make it public not yet so that's the
basic workflow there are millions of
subcategories in the workflow tell me to
everyone to see the workflow plan i'd be
happy to share it with you um let me say
a few words about metadata where's our
Melanie that's metadata right there this
photo is actually called you know the
title this is graffiti and little boy
now now speaking of metadata some of the
photos come with a title that was
written on the back I'll show you some
of these some of them come with a title
that was assigned when it was published
in a community service society pamphlet
or newsletter or annual report some of
them have no titles we're assigning a
title to each of them I'm not sure
whether we assign this one of that was
in there I have to figure that one out
but it's important to the patrons to
know the metadata right it's less
important to community service society
necessarily if they want to use a photo
in a brochure who did it but for
scholars and researchers they want to
know who created it what the date was
where was it who's in the photo in some
cases and so we're
endeavoring to do that and that's what
makes it valuable that's the value add
to just scanning the photos and putting
them up and saying bunch of crowd source
of that your dad it's different we're
expertly applying these categories to
the photos we created a data dictionary
of about 30 different metadata items we
took existing metadata in the archive
the finding aid has some there are nine
binders of these type sheets I talked
about and then there are occasional
annotations directly on the photo a
graduate student took that data and
entered it into the administrative
interface that's stage one before the
photos are even sent down for scanning
stage two is that my colleagues and W
graphic control or I keep forgetting the
name so I'm going to forget it now using
a library of congress controlled
vocabularies did extensive work in
figuring out what other categories we
can assign to each of the photos subject
access geographic access all sorts of
things i'm going to show you each a
couple of examples to give you an idea
of what we're creating with this with
some date issues which my colleagues
wanted me to bring up as well there are
the display dates the i legible dates
1919 where we know for sure
approximately nineteen nineteen that's
how it will appear between 1990 19 and
then there's the dates the structured
form dates for searching again if you
want to use the photo to advocate for
the poor it may not matter to you what
the date is is just oh my god a poor
child with crutches that's one use if
you want to use it for scholarship and
no higher a meijer did these photos
between nineteen seventeen and nineteen
eighteen in this part of the lower east
side you want to know the dates and
again that's the value air that no crowd
sourcing is going to do for you we had a
lot of other challenges going along um
these are some of them I'm not going to
go too much into them but the raw Aussie
are had to be scanned right and then it
had to be corrected we had to figure out
what the how we're going to formulate
titles for photographs you know what are
we going to say how many mother not to
assume with someone's a mother and child
because it's a woman in a child sitting
together if you have a lot of pictures
with woman and child you to describe
each one differently so each photograph
has a unique title um we had to create
transcription rules because the back of
each photograph has different stuff
written on it not
sticky black glue but stamps of the
photographic auntie the Creator that did
it various descriptions of the
photographs strange numbers we had to
figure all that out and dump it into the
into the database and then the
publication format what's it going to
look like oh sorry the publication
format would be if it appeared in a
community service society publication
what format do we use to cite that
publication there's a dispute between
just pretending to be a librarian to
academic and me about well bibliographic
citation why come from a bibliography
and academic paper looks like this and
librarian saying no no no bibliographic
it should look like this we come to some
useful um collaboration that gives us
the term this is the administrative
interface I'm going to take you in and
show you some things
okay so let me show you how how we
manage the items that's interesting why
doesn't it appear so the photos appear
on here I think that parts cut off no
it's over to here should be should be
over here I'll go in there anyway these
usually a little thumbnail the photo in
there okay so you go into each item well
here's how it appears you can see the
the metadata categories this is the
photo you saw the Jesse tarbox bills
child's in the photograph that's the
front that's the back these are all the
categories the top stuff is pulled
directly from the metadata we have an
RBI mal the graduate student types it in
and enters it's interesting because
there were 30 metadata items that's a
1500 photographs that's what 45,000
items so for me I came from a corporate
environment one percent error rate is
perfectly fine but my friends in library
said no way you can't have a one percent
error rate everything's got to be
absolutely correct so we've had to go
back and correct a lot of things thank
God been helping out to correct a lot of
things um in here but let me show you
for example what the students working
with is the photo you can enlarge it you
can look at the back right so identifies
the Creator in this case gives it a
number many of the photos had their own
assigned numbers by the CSS we don't
know why or how but they'll have an
assigned number we're capturing that as
well you can see the structured metadata
down the bottom the stuff in the middle
right here this stuff is all on the
typed sheet that was OCR scanned in OC
yard and put in here so now researcher
can come in well let me research you can
see all this information I'll go and go
into how they use it in a moment there
they are that's how it really appears up
then I
let me show you something else how about
this which Stewart did ransom software
which went through all the photos pulled
out the faces for each of the photos and
put them up there and then you can go to
a photo what do you want with that guy
and find out where it is so assuming
you're interested in genealogical
information about your relatives on the
Lower East Side i should point out the
vast majority of these photographs are
white working poor on the Lower East
Side of New York from the late 1880s
through the 1930s the vast majority
there's some african-americans from the
19 late 1920s around columbus circle to
San Juan Hill area but that's the vast
majority of the photographs so you can
pull out individual faces assuming you
want to do that we have term frequency
lists that go to creators these are some
of them that go to the topic subjects
when I was trying to figure out how am I
going to represent metadata what could i
use I look through my list that that
that that that that I look at that
graffiti that could work and I pull that
photo out so if you want to search by
category you can do that by subject name
by geographic subjects so it's a quite
robust and interesting administrative
interface this is not though to be clear
what it's going to look like for the end
user we're still working on that but it
really allows us from anywhere to manage
the items right the student can be
typing in the data in one part of the
library other colleagues can be scanning
information I can be working from home
looking at correcting data we can all be
working in this one space at the same
time saving time and money to get it
done right now we're up to eight hundred
some-odd I think 912 so you can see
these are the data is typed in here but
the images have not been scanned because
it's kind of a rolling process right you
type in the data you scan some lady your
type in more data you scan some after
that so I really like interface for
working with that it's it's beautiful
well I'm speaking too fast
crazy New York ripped through my
presentation no one likes a all right
let's say where am I so let me just go
back here okay enlighten me where's my
presentation okay crunch slide okay i
just took some screenshots in case it
didn't work ok what's the user
experience going to be as we used to say
in business what's the patron going to
see when she goes there we don't know
yet we know it's going to be easy to use
they're gonna be able to search by all
sorts of different categories like
creator boy school girl mother graffiti
we know they're gonna be able to
download not very low resolution decent
resolution items to use them and we know
there's gonna be some narrative
introduction to the text at the front of
it it's going to make I think our job
serving patrons much much easier because
we can direct them to this site it's
going to make research has access
incredibly easy the scholar in Spain i
can write her and say by the way go in
here you can find all the Huayra myers
photos now from where you are does
everything that digitization is supposed
to do in an effective interesting way
and i think it's a pretty great project
so i always close with this is my
collaborators from limer hope I didn't
miss anyone and I close with questions
guys under 30 minutes my god I gotta
slow down questions questions hi I was
wondering which software you used and do
people have the capability to zoom in on
a photograph so um we're not going to
jpeg 2000 s but because we have the
JPEGs that we have now are so large that
you really can get a lot of detail so we
won't have that type of like a zoomify
I'm sorry another question was it was
all we built everything we did locally
yeah we built the software in house it's
not only it's that complex is it we
should license didn't make some money
for God's sake how many of these people
are actually identify identified oh
that's a great question how many them
are identified in the photos because I'm
thinking about
you about crowdsourcing yeah once it's
up there we certainly could provide
something for people to comment on them
very few the more identified but there
are some photos on which names are
written like a bald Ozzy family Hester
Street is written on them but very very
few of them is usually mother and child
mother at dental clinic child at dental
clinic nurses at Columbus Circle very
few i would say way less than 1% right
now i mean yeah i just wanted to know if
you're using EAD to to use to change it
into a markup extensible i mean to
change it into a mark record so that you
could put them on sorry dressing and now
for your answer we actually use mods for
most of our digital collections as a
metadata schema of choice so eid is used
for the finding aids for that level of
description but for the item level
description for use mods this is the
same administrative interface we use for
the lungs fest right linquist hi is
there any concern about interoperability
with other sort of annotated sets of
historical photographs that are out
there or under creation I mean so a
couple things one is there is part of
the administrative interface allows you
to search the web for other photographs
for matches which seems to have worked
well and then poorly recently so there
is that but I don't know if we thought
further about what interoperability
would mean that's why we are using
controlled vocabularies that are also
used in other collections so that that
will make it easier to search across at
some point if we make it available that
way
thank you very much thank you very much
now our next speakers are Heather
Saunders and Ryan Taylor from University
of Toronto and SUNY Purchase and they're
going to talk about the art and
environment of embedded librarianship
I'm Heather Saunders and this is ryan
taylor and we're going to speak to you
about a collaboration that took place
about a year and a half ago at Purchase
College which is a state university of
new york campus in westchester county
and pardon me at the time i was working
as art librarian currently i work in
canada as a controlled vocabulary
specialist and ryan continues to work in
natural sciences at purchase college and
just to jump in embedded librarianship
is a hot term that's being tossed around
these days and frequently it's in the
context of teaching technically you can
be an embedded librarian by for example
attending faculty meetings for
departments but generally that term gets
used in the context of education and
that's the context that will be
discussing it as well and our hope is
that by revisiting this experience today
in the context of some of the recent
scholarship that we might be able to put
together some ideas that you might
implement on your own campus and see
what works for you and what wouldn't
work for you necessarily so this is an
overview of what will be going through
today and we'll be discussing the needs
and opportunities to have embedded
librarians on campuses and how you might
go about doing that and what the pros
and cons are of having an embedded
librarian okay and as Heather said I'm
the token non librarian of this team so
I'm a little out of my element here I'm
also on sabbatical the semester so I'm a
little out of my element for speaking a
little bit too so so forgive me a little
bit here but I am an environmental
scientist and as an environmental
scientist I see the world a certain way
the way I see the world is very
simplistic I see the world is made up of
an abiotic component that is consists of
matter and consists of energy and I see
the world consisting of a biotic
component the living things that are
part of our environment and in my world
view i also see things that humans do
that can cause life
to be harmed and things that humans can
do that can cause life to be restored
that's the way I see the world I and I
don't see the world in terms of
vocabulary that we've been talking about
these mark and adis and I'm sorry this
is the way I see the world and it is a
little abstract still and it is a little
simplistic and reductionist I admit that
so I don't try to teach this in my intro
to environmental science class alone I
do reference the science literature and
try to get these concepts to make sense
and stick the term we call stickiness
sticky information as a science educator
how do we get this to stick with our
students and I am advised from the
science literature to try and give these
students to do to students what I've
done with this particular one here where
I try to give them hands-on experience
let them collect their own actual data
and to do it by all means in the real
world that this is stuff that is
supposed to make science especially
environmental science make more sense to
students the problem is I still have a
fair percentage of my students who still
just don't get it and I don't think it's
so much a problem with my students as
much it is a problem with our
methodology in the environmental
sciences or at least in science
education that when we try to apply a
science education model to environmental
sciences it's a little incomplete
because environmental science is dealing
with that human dimension what is it
that's causing humans as a society to
harm their environment and what is the
cultural ramifications of living in a
harmed environment that these are things
that sitting there with an instrument at
a table next to a lake is never going to
help you answer and so there are things
about an environmental issue that are a
little more complex that deals with
humans relationships and so if you look
in the current environmental education
literature there winds up being quite a
bit being written currently and it
didn't use to always be there about the
idea of could we use art could we use
art to help educate students could art
help make the information
more sticky because artists have a long
history of helping explain things that
are complex that are about relationships
and that wind up being things that allow
us to see the unseen you have aha
moments when you experience art you
understand something in a deeper level
now I can go out and I can teach
students about air air currents and
thatthat's that some air currents are
very small and don't produce very much
energy some air currents are very large
and therefore do have a lot of energy in
them and I can do that with a little
mini wind turbine or show them images of
giant wind turbines or I can take them
out to see a couple of kinetic
sculptures one by George Ricky that
operates and will move and change shape
and form in interesting ways if the wind
blows very lightly or I can take them to
see an artwork by marc de severo who his
works will move and bow and change
direction and shape and form if the wind
blows very largely and the idea is if I
show this to students as opposed to some
abstract windmill somewhere some
scientific instrument they might get
they might get it a little bit better it
might stick with them a little bit more
so that's just one example there's all
kinds of examples where there are
artists who intentionally go out and
work with natural materials and are
trying to draw their their patrons
attention towards things like natural
processes now Ricky and deceiver o are
not necessarily doing that so much
they're not they're not trying to
illuminate nature's forces as much as
they are trying to show how their
sculptures can jump in and live but
there are some artists who really do
take that the environment into
consideration with their works and there
are artists whose works are not
environmental in nature but they place
them in the environment and you can see
things like how contrasting human
development can be to nature what the
contrast can be just by seeing these non
natural features and how much larger
than life and out of scale with nature
human actions can be and hopefully that
makes it make a little makes it stay
with students a little more if they see
the message this way
as opposed to just trying to see it
through a scientific lens likewise it
can give them an idea of what the future
is was possible to give them ideas to
see forms that they aren't used to
seeing in ways to see an envision a
potential new future so this is the hope
this is the idea that's coming out of
environmental literature let's be more
transdisciplinary let's do let's be more
collaborative let's bring people from
the Arts in to help us understand the
sciences a little bit better so I
thought well let's jump on board with
this and let's create a unit for my
intro to environmental science course
which is a gen Ed's satisfier for
science that would have a section just
one unit on environmental art and
thought i would give this a try the
problem is i am also not only not a
librarian i am not an artist nor do i
know much about art really but as a
scientist I know to do research and when
I do research I go to my library and
when i go to my library i seek help from
my librarian so i contacted my subject
specialist who is the environmental
studies librarian and i asked i asked
leah messer i asked her if she could
help me and leah ultimately referred me
to heather so i'm going to turn the talk
over to Heather here for a little bit
i'm just laying the groundwork for why
we started working together so there's a
little bit more to the story leah is
both the science subject specialist and
the head of reference at purchase
college and so she certainly goes the
extra mile for trying to make a
reference interview go really really
well and she knew at the time that I was
covering the visual resources department
as well as being art librarian there was
a maternity leave at the time and so I
was the logical person to go to to help
find art images for a natural sciences
professor but one of the things that
came up sort of serendipitously she was
searching for journal articles as some
background context and ended up tripping
across profile I had written a few years
back about to environmental artists and
this caused her to realize that even
within our small group of librarians who
ate lunch together every day and
collaborated on projects we didn't even
necessarily know what our
our own strengths were what all of our
resources were within our own tiny
little group and as a result of that we
started going for coffee once a month
exclusively to talk about what we were
doing professionally so that everyone
knew what their collective worth was
because I think if you want to
collaborate with your colleagues you
really want to make it worth their while
so you need to communicate your worth
but you need to communicate your own
worth to your immediate colleagues in
your library to kind of get past those
barriers and embed yourself yeah okay so
as you can see it with Heather you get a
little more than I was bargaining for I
was going to the library just looking
for someone who's a little flexible who
can provide me some library support on
doing some research on some images and I
wound up getting someone who had a lot
more to offer and I'm sure that's going
to be the case of everybody in this room
that we're multi-dimensional people to
the T and every one of us can probably
do more than what actually is written
somewhere in the brief description of I
am such an such subject librarian
everyone knows what that means and we
can go on so after we put together this
this one unit and Heather help me put
this unit together we presented it and
I'll be darned if it didn't work it
wound up being a huge success which was
good because Purchase College for those
of you who know this do it does have a
an art reputation and and we do have
sort of that vibe on campus and an
interest of our students and they really
were very positively reviewed that part
of our of our class so shortly after
that class was done the next semester a
couple of things happened on campus one
of the things happened was the
administration announced that our annual
our annual theme for the next year was
going to be about the environment
environment is everything and I was just
like yes I've come to the right place
this is a great school they they really
value the right things well so they they
created this theme for the next year and
what basically they want everyone on
campus try to come up with some way to
tie into the campus theme the other
thing that happened was our Provost
decided that that he wanted to make a
priori
of of collaboration and he wanted it to
be interdisciplinary so he was really
focusing on getting faculty professors
especially to work across campus and
other disciplines to put together
co-developed co-taught
cross-disciplinary courses and that was
sort of an OLE and so he put together
this tuple grant program was an internal
to the college competitive grant where a
couple of faculty could work together
design a interdisciplinary course and
the the college would produce some
funding to allow us to spend a little
time in the summer to develop that
course and to provide some additional
support for our for our course expenses
now some colleges and I don't
necessarily have these same sort of
internal financial problems but I can't
hide purchase or at least sunnis
financial problems from anybody
especially given the writings that are
in the newspaper these days so to have a
grant that was supporting this
particular program was very enticing so
Heather and I were both new to the
College were both eager to make our mark
on the campus and we had worked together
pretty well to develop one unit so I
thought to myself I wonder if Heather
would be interested in embedding herself
in my class and and coming and being a
partner with me in developing a topol
grant so we could see if we could put
together a interdisciplinary course so
so I came together with this particular
proposal so here are some factors to
consider my impulse generally when I
have an opportunity is say us now and
figure out the details later but it's
probably a good idea to consider some of
the factors so first of all how high
profile is the collaboration that you
are able to dive into if you do one shot
bibliographic instruction session and it
doesn't go well maybe you've got a
migraine no one's going to hear about it
because no one's going to bother talking
about it but if it's an entire course
people will be watching so that's one
factor to consider secondly
administrative support so Ryan mentioned
that we certainly had reason to believe
that our Provost would be excited about
it
and consequently the library director as
well we were both on tenure tracks and
so it really made sense to collaborate
and i think that the collaboration is
the key component of this type of
endeavor and pardon me we also had the
advantage of because we knew that the
campus theme was environment is
everything the library was anticipating
more research in this area and so we
started to bolster our collection
accordingly and this offset one of the
potential frustrations that's been
identified for embedded librarians which
is not having a sufficient collection to
enhance that collaboration and next up
is a track record do you have a track
record to build off of so in our case we
did have this one isolated lecture that
we could use as a model and in our case
we're hoping that if you haven't tried
anything like this perhaps today's
session might inform the direction you
might take and act as a jumping-off
point and lastly is there someone you
can trust so of today's a classic
example I'm recovering from laryngitis
and Ryan I needed to be able to trust
him that if I was sick and delayed in
Canada he could step in and speak as a
librarian in a librarian symposium and I
knew that he would pull through and
likewise he would need to trust that if
I couldn't make it i would keep the
lines of communication open constantly
so i think this is a classic example of
needing to have absolute trust with the
person that you're collaborating with so
here we are in our overview I'll just
flip pass this that's okay so here we
are my weaknesses so I never taught a
university class before aside from doing
bibliographic instruction classes but it
seemed like an exciting opportunity I'm
not an environmentalist although I had
taken a few have heard me a few
environmental studies courses and there
was certainly time constraints that was
probably the biggest challenge my home
unit was very supportive our library
director was really excited and thought
this was a great opportunity but he
certainly let the responsibility rest
with me saying you know let me let me
know what you need from me and sometimes
it's hard to ask for help if you don't
know exactly
what you need so for example we had my
colleagues filling in for me at the
reference desk because it's taking you
away from the front lines but you really
need to be communicating with your
colleagues why you need them to fill in
for you and how it's benefiting the
profile of the library in general and
not just you as a you know tenure-track
faculty member who's you know just
trying to look after their own needs so
I think it's some really important to
communicate with your colleagues so that
it seems like a shared endeavor not just
something that one person is doing in
terms of those time constraints and also
um I was unable to get compensatory pay
to develop the course throughout the
summer which meant that Ryan did a lot
of the heavy lifting with the course
preparations and while this disparity
does reflect a lot of the embedded
librarianship teaching that currently
exists it's not really the model that we
were after we were really searching for
more of a co instructional model so in
terms of answering the knock Carson and
Neil pardon me suggest that you accept
the risk move outside your comfort zone
and act outside the box and certainly
that's what this endeavor represented so
the idea of the class when we go from
this we go from this one unit component
to a core science class to change this
into a full semester long class what we
were doing was we were wanting to teach
about environmental concepts but we
didn't want students to research the
environment we wanted students to
research artists we wanted them to
research their works and that's nothing
I am capable of doing which is why I
really needed someone in the class who
could help students research art and to
and to do it from the perspective of of
the of the collections that we had
available and to help use the resources
especially the electronic resources that
we had on campus and so we needed
someone to I needed someone to help me
do that part of the class research art
to understand the environment and when
we put this class together it was clear
that this was going to require a lot of
work on the half on behalf of Heather as
the librarian an equal amount of work
even even though
as she mentioned she wasn't able to
receive the the total compensation for
the summer for the course development
when it came time to putting the class
together she we were going to be side by
side by side and shoulder to shoulder in
the in the trenches on this class so we
wanted to make very clear to everyone
that we work 0 equals on this so when we
came time to listing the course with the
registrar and and making everything
available to the students and to the
administration that it was clear we were
jointly instructing this course that we
were equals an our eyes to each other in
the administration's eyes and in the
eyes of the students the idea they're
being that that if we are if we are true
partners equal partners in this that
that we will be able to collaborate
together and be able to work in a very
meaningful and constructive way so the
way this wound up working so we're going
to get into some of the logistics of
this now should you decide to get into
doing a collaborative project with
someone in this sort of embedded way the
way this work was I would be responsible
for the environmental literature because
I had been teaching courses at the
school I was also responsible for
anything that looked like paperwork yeah
especially we organizing class field
trip so we're taking students off-site
we're trying to get guest artists try to
get them an honorarium paid we're trying
to get make sure that that that the
faculty and students and the visual arts
side of our campus are aware of what
we're doing in this class a that it's an
option for their students but be that
that that that we're having guest
speakers and things that are open to
them to for them to come and visit and
to and for putting together the course
and administering it through Moodle
which is our course software the
equivalent to blackboard a lot of places
so there would be the stuff that I would
handle and interestingly we went for an
even split for the readings pretty much
half environmental content half art
content to really give them a balance to
not make it bias towards one subject or
the other I also make gallery
recommendations so Ryan was the one who
headed up
these excursions to very large literally
large field trips where they'd be out
walking for hours on the grass looking
at sculptures but I directed the
students to smaller venues smaller
galleries in New York City and local
areas where they could go and comment on
the exhibition and we'd already worked
on writing critical analyses of still
images of artwork and so then it was a
great move to go from that to a gallery
environment and use those same skills
and then once they were comfortable with
that once they'd been interacting with
curators at galleries they were ready to
curate their own show so we had the
students create a gallery show of art
made from recycled materials will show
you some images in a minute and that was
in the library and that necessitated
having a liaison because we didn't want
our library director to be surprised by
all of a sudden there's students
patching up the walls or you know doing
something strange climbing up on you
know little areas to try to fit in
sculptures and what's going on so I was
the liaison for that and probably the
most overt librarian role I had in this
capacity was helping the students to
navigate through the classroom
management software but otherwise I
didn't really have a really forceful
approach to it was almost like I was
more there's a subject specialist who
happened to be there co-instructor and
who happened to also work at the library
but I don't think that the students
necessarily saw me as a librarian who's
sitting in on the class which i think
worked well I think it felt a little
more natural so the rest of the
logistics were more or less how we would
put a unit together how would we work
that's art that's sort of like how the
students solve division of labor this is
sort of behind the scenes on how we
would develop a unit and so one of the
things that that we would do is I would
come up I would I would comb through the
environmental literature and I would
come up with at least a couple of
artists who are working with an
environmental issue that I would like
for the students to better understand
and I would kick those artists over to
Heather okay gesture sorry and then I
would look for images that would be sort
of the key images from those artists the
famous ones are the ones that really
encapsulate encapsulated an idea
and then we kind of fine tune the list
of artists that would be appropriate for
the lecture right so Heather would
expand the list she would give me more
options than I knew were available and
then she would give me their whole
bodies of work or at least large
portions of their bodies of work I would
then go through that and think about the
environmental issue I wanted to focus on
for the day what is this environmental
topic and an artist might produce a
whole bunch of a whole huge body work
talk because spanning a whole bunch of
subjects and so we would call out those
ones that were specific and would kind
of revolve around this one issue for the
day and so with I'd say okay just these
let's talk about just these and I and I
could see like the heart crushing of
true art historians and art librarians
what are you doing what are you doing
you're taking this but I was talking
about the environment so I felt I had
license there and so I say let's just
let's just focus on this um and then and
then Heather would then take that you
want me just do this person here Heather
Heather would Heather would take it and
would sort of construct a historical
time with you she would try to piece
back the fabric that I had ripped
completely out of it all right so that
there was context for the students and
the idea of this was that in the
lectures that we would give them a
concept here's environmental concept
here are some artists here are some key
Sentinel works on this now during the
class as you spend some time looking up
the rest of that artists work you
research more about this artist find out
more about what they're doing find out
more about their work and we would do
that in the classroom with Heather sort
of guidance on looking for these kinds
of things so so just sort of like
paralleling back the making it a
skeleton so the students could flesh it
back out again was sort of the idea so I
would then take Heather's back
reconstructed thing and I would put it
back together into into an organized
lecture and and then we would roll with
it sort of doing like we're doing here
today each of us sort of handing off
part of the lecture and covering the
next part kind of thing okay so my
initial involvement with the course
really did just start with image
research and it kind of went from there
it was basically a matter of translating
library science as worded by Carson and
kneel to the disciplines of
environmental science and art history
and this reinforced my role as provider
of in-depth research as Allah varies
calls
but this role really did evolve quickly
once Ryan learned more about my
background working in galleries and my
masters in art history it made sense to
kind of pull from where we could to make
it the richest course possible and that
reflects shoemaker and tallies
observation the embedded librarians tend
to have a background in the subject
matter that's important to their
customer group and because they suggest
that embedded librarianship should be
customer centric not library centric I
move beyond the image research and into
more theoretical research without
forcing an agenda of information
literacy so it seemed more important to
make it a really rich art experience or
probably from my side of things I saw it
as an art experience in your side maybe
environmental experience then for me to
be functioning as a really obvious
librarian oh sorry this is me again um
in the year tooth pardon me in the year
2000 rasp and ward envisioned a world
where novel instructional pairings and
collaborations between members of the
academic community will be commonplace
and yet even a decade later it seems
that embedded librarianship is outside
of the the target of work plan of a lot
of librarians and what results from that
is that it's hard to manage all of your
responsibilities so of course it's great
to be embedded in somebody's classroom
but you still have your normal
obligations like sitting the reference
desk or in my case I was also covering a
maternity leave so you still have all
these things that are going on and I
think part of the challenge is that
there's sort of a gray zone where
librarians exist in our case our library
director would start jokingly refer to
the trying to think how it was phrased
again I think it was the teaching
faculty and the non teaching faculty is
what the majority of the campus referred
to so he would talk about the librarian
and non librarian faculty being kind of
to get into the politics of you know
where do librarians exist and can they
be valued in this kind of encounter and
so fortunately our administration was
really supportive but we did have a
number of challenges so for example I
have a 12 month or
had pardon me a twelvemonth appointment
and Ryan had a nine-month appointment so
that would interfere with when you start
planning the course the summer time for
example when people might be busier you
know out in the water taking samples
then preparing a course because that's
their their obligation for the school
with their contract and different
10-year standards fortunately it was
seen as a positive move for me to try
this type of thing but still there were
certainly workload expectations that I
really did need to rely on Ryan to do
the heavy lifting because it was hard to
get away as much as I would have liked
to have gotten away to work on the
course and one of the one of the one of
being sort of a technical issue with the
tenure standards was because this was a
co instructed course we only had one
still only had one course evaluation
which says evaluate your instructor and
and not to not evaluate Heather then
evaluate Ryan it was evaluate your
instructor and as a as a tenure track
professor those those evaluations are
very very important so we were so we may
we had to wind up making clear for
students that that that the the teacher
evaluations we're not going to factor
into Heather's tenure consideration they
were going to factor into mine so when
you do this fill it out for me and so
there wasn't an opportunity to fill it
out a separate type of thing for Heather
and so that was sort of it as one of
those situations where we tried the best
we darn could to make this equal and
then when it came down to evaluating it
we you know we either we dropped the
ball or we just couldn't do it one way
or the other and so this sort of just
something I wanted to highlight to keep
you guys abreast of how that kind of
worked out there do you wanted it this
part you want me to look at you alright
so one of the things that we were really
excited about was that there was kind of
a dual model of embeddedness so usually
when you hear of embedded librarians the
librarian is taken out of the library
and isn't another classroom or somewhere
outside the library that's sort of the
the key component in our case we
actually had the course within the
library
and so that offered it was really
exciting because it would mean that
students would be closer to the
reference desk and studies showed that
there tends to be an increase in
reference questions when you have
embedded librarians and the students
would be walking past the reference desk
as they exited it was the only path out
of the library or when they were done
class if they wanted to check out a book
on an artist that they just learned
about they had that opportunity so it
was really a chance to welcome an active
library users and so that was quite
exciting so very similar to Colombia's
layout you know with the libraries being
right in the center of campus our
library also is in the center campus we
only think only real difference I'm not
going to being a little tongue-in-cheek
is we just have one library and it's and
it's quite a bit smaller but but on our
campus you know we've got the natural
science side of the campus and then
we've got the artist side of the campus
and never the twain shall meet right so
where can you find common ground for the
for the for everyone right in the middle
right right in the library right in this
neutral ground this this place where
everyone can get together and everyone
can kind of feel like this is this is
theirs everyone has their own ownership
over this and this is from the students
perspective right like I'm never going
to walk into that science class that's
why I came into that science building
it's why I came to purchase or I'm never
going over to that art side I'm a
scientist darn it so so the idea that
okay we'll put this in the middle you
know sort of had common ground for the
students but also from a college
politics sort of side of things you're
not going to have the scientists come
into your art building and teaching art
class are you I mean who is he you know
to be able to do that or worse how could
how dare he have it in the science
building where we can't keep an eye on
it so put it in the library that way
everyone can see it and it's right there
and everyone can feel like it's all
something they have ownership wound up
being a sort of a a very useful tactic
for us and give you this sort of layout
of our library a little bit here this
isn't all the library but this is sort
of the central floor of the library
and when it came time to doing the class
you can see that nothing in here is
listed as an actual lecture hall or or
true classroom the best we had were
these computer labs which actually
worked well for us because we wanted
students researching more about the the
artists as we talked about them we
wanted them to get online so we chose
one of the computer labs to be our
classroom and we're not the kind of
college that encourages everyone or
requires everyone to have a laptop that
kind of thing so to have a class with
students having the omnipresent internet
right in front of them between you and
them is sort of a big deal and so but we
wanted that to happen so we could say
here is a particular artist visit their
website and look at some more of their
work so that was something that we that
wound up working very well for us the
other thing when we had visiting artists
you can imagine a visiting artist would
not really want to exhibit their art in
a computer lab as they're coming to talk
about their methods but we did have a
very nice reference room which did which
it has kind of the dark woods in the
very kind of a nice arrangement and and
and we would invite the public to come
see these these speakers and they would
come they're not in our computer lab to
come talk and that wound up working out
very well for us but then the third part
of the class or maybe it's the fourth
part or fifth at this point in time of a
class was we wanted the students to make
their art to do an art exhibit have a
place to exhibit the work again not very
good exhibition places in the Natural
Sciences Building is it really artists
work to be in the visual arts building
maybe we can do it in the library and
the library does have a number of places
where they do exhibit spaces they do
have exhibition places but we were able
to kind of through Heather's liaison was
able to sort of smooth out our own
little corner of a of the lobby area in
Turia lobby area to host our exhibition
where then the the trash the actual name
of the exhibit was able to get a lot of
a lot of view and a lot of profile right
where it was where people could could
could see it sorry
so this was really exciting it really
was the highlight of the course I think
for a number of students they mentioned
this they'd spent the semester learning
about art and many of them were from a
studio background very few of them were
but they really i think by the time they
got excited about art and then got to
the end of the semester they were
comfortable picking a theme together
they chose trash as their theme and
these are a few of the works here one is
all pop bottles or soda bottles pardon
me and the middle one is very meditative
it's a rolled up newspaper so about
recycling and the one on the right is
all cigarette butts I think hundreds of
them that were picked up on campus and
this is one of the ones that we actually
contained in a display case just to
contain the smell we actually had
someone one of our librarians was
pregnant at the time and so there's all
sorts of factors you think you've
thought of everything and then you know
there's someone who's pregnant who is
reacting to a gigantic cigarette but
this is the kind of work that the
students came up with they were so proud
and I really think that there was a lot
of activism as well as aesthetics which
is great and the image on the left here
shows that the students had stacked up
furniture to have more novel display
units and on the right hand side we've
got the library director as well as the
director of environmental studies and
one of the students and we also had some
money in our budget for reception so
we've got some food here and we had
flyers and it was a little down to the
wire I had to coach the students on all
of the steps that are involved in
putting on an exhibition and it wasn't
until just the last minute the Aquino
crack of dawn that they really started
printing the flyers and you know getting
excited about the food and inviting
their friends but it all came together
just at the last minute which was
amazing and you can imagine from the
perspective of the library director all
you're going to have this art class and
they're going to make art out of trash
they're digging out of the dumpsters and
they're going to plaster it all over the
walls great great so we had a real
opportunity to fall totally flat on our
face in a lot of ways with this class
and one of them was hinging on these non
art students making good art that is a
benefit to the law
right that would help the library bring
people to it and make it a space that
folks would want to come into and sorry
I also forgot to mention that the show
was launched on Earth Day and ran until
graduation so it was a really great time
to a very high profile in terms of
having more people in the library than
usual this was actually around the time
that the library introduced its 24 7 or
maybe twenty four five hours during exam
periods students would be with their
sleeping bags and there you know kettle
of tea and so we really did get a lot of
people viewing the show which is great
this is just a quick slide to show you
the artist and resonance for the visual
arts program christine lee she was
working with repurposed materials as our
campus was being renovated and she built
these modular benches which is great
because the students were actually
involved with a student library advisory
committee on giving us ideas about what
they would like to see for furniture and
so when christine lee left campus when
she finished her residency the library
director consulted with me about adding
them to the library which may have
happened without this entire endeavor
but you know maybe maybe he consulted
with me because he saw our exhibition
planning prowess or whatever but the
point is that today these remain part of
the library so even though the trash
works are no longer there there's still
sort of a component of that okay and
just to conclude melvil dewey stated the
time is when a library is a school and
the librarian is in the highest sense a
teacher and the course that we taught at
Purchase College we believe demonstrates
the library's capacity to function as a
classroom as well as the ability of a
librarian to act as a co-instructor and
that it really does represent the the
fruits that can come from combining your
efforts with your colleagues ultimately
the course was deemed successful by the
administrators and by our respective
colleagues but most importantly by the
students so unfortunately in those
evaluations that Ryan mentioned they did
go above and beyond just commenting on
Ryan and kind of commented on the
overall dynamic by saying that they
thought the collaboration between a
professor and a librarian made the class
atmosphere more dynamic and really
that's that's all the encouragement you
need is just one comment like that to
know that it was worthwhile as Schumaker
notes the task of developing the
embedded library
raines role is not finished in keeping
with hiders last of 10 tips for
successfully embedding yourself we took
the time to engage in some professional
development at the end of all of this so
we traveled to Toronto Canada to be part
of the arts for social and environmental
justice symposium and it was a really
great chance to reflect on how
everything had gone and what we might do
differently in the future and to talk to
other people from other schools about
what they thought about our project and
hopefully that's sort of what we're
doing here as well today pardon me and
this is noted that it's um this step is
often missed an embedded librarianship
so we highly encourage you that if you
do embark on embedded librarianship take
the time to kind of plan out some of the
administrative challenges beforehand but
also give yourself an opportunity to
reflect on it afterwards and and we hope
that if you do work with mix programs
different different disciplines like
natural sciences and art that you might
consider embedding some courses in the
library and not just bringing librarians
outside of the library thank
Ryan is there an alternative course that
you or someone else teaches it it's SUNY
Purchase in which discusses either the
political or the technical aspects of
our mental science yeah during an
alternative course either you or someone
else that purchased teaches discussing
the technical or political aspects of
environmental science well we t we teach
a number of classes in our and our
program that there's a policy course
that's focuses solely on environmental
policy then there are more technical
classes like regulations there are
ecology courses human ecology I mean we
have very specific classes that wind up
being single discipline though and this
was the we do have a few that are
cross-disciplinary like environmental
journalism where where one of the
professors dr. Kramer teaches it with it
with it with a journalist professor so
and then and then they art in the
environment course and then we're
developing an art history course as well
that'll be a co instructed course so we
do have some courses that are co-taught
with other faculty and but we do have
multiple environmental courses that
students take where they deal with
different issues around the environment
to that okay all right this isn't the
only environmental course we have
do you have any suggestions for doing
outreach with faculty because typically
at the campus I met we don't have many
faculty coming to the library and saying
could you take over half of my course um
so what what tips do you have for doing
outreach is that for you Heather I don't
know that's for you this might be a
question for me I guess it might be sort
of a vague answer but I think finding a
way to communicate your willingness and
your worth I guess in my situation I
kind of had a another embedded
librarianship opportunity which was
sitting on a board of study which is
kind of like in a department and I think
if you can be out there and in a
completely different context from what
you're actually after so say I was
taking minutes and faculty meetings but
at least it got me in touch with my
colleagues and so I think if I tried to
broach something like this with one of
them it would have I would have had a
better shot at it from I guess doing
them a favor but I think that's probably
something that we still need to think
about I guess I guess getting getting
this hypothetical support of a library
director in advance so that if you're in
a conversation with somebody you can let
them know that the opportunity exists I
guess it would be very risky to kind of
indicate your willingness and then find
out that you don't have the resources to
support you while you're actually trying
to make it happen yeah I think if
there's anything I can add to that it's
it's the fact that we were in two
different programs or two different
specializations to where the need wasn't
necessarily coming to Heather where she
might have thought the need would come
from that she wasn't coming someone
wasn't coming to her from the art
history or the visual arts faculty but
it was coming from someone on the
outside where you know if you think
about it I'm the one who needed to help
the most for for her not so much for a
classroom instruction so that's that's
the other thing I think is to think
about where your radars is aimed for
looking at opportunities coming
hi thank you for your presentation it's
a great example of an academic
collaboration with the library and
academic department I'm just wondering
if it was just a one-off or has it
inspired other courses like this at suny
purchase or is there now a place in your
library for an academic department to
have a sort of a foothold there's get
there's a few things wrapped in that the
library does have some other sort of
like they have they have a Writing
Center where the creative writing
Department has has a group of visiting
writers come and they and they and they
work there helping students do writing
and so there's a couple of other
circumstances like that that happened on
campus along with like digital media
they have a whole digital media zone
there that's that's all set up for for
the visual arts folks to come in there
and do their class instruction in the
library as a part of that and for that
to be available studio space for the
students in the visual arts department
now in terms of has the school pursued
other embedded librarianship
rearrangements like what Heather and I
have had I don't know that that's
happened anyplace else yet but I know
that this particular visual arts kind of
idea environmental idea is evolving more
and that we're going to be doing more of
that kind of thing whether or not
involves the library I don't know just
add to that I my understanding was that
the director was open to it and I know
that part of the reason I wasn't able to
get compensatory pay was because the
attitude was well what if other
librarians want to jump on board and
they also want to teach how will we
budget for this so that indicated that
there's an openness to it but it would
be up to the individual librarians with
their own workload and their own goals
but your question raises an interesting
point there was another librarian at the
school at the time who was amazingly
outgoing with her faculty and she was
part of a sort of unofficial embedded
librarianship endeavor she sat in on at
least half of the classes & Co wrote an
article with an instructor but because
it was never formalised I don't think
that it gained the recognition that it
deserves so kind of a tangent but I
would recommend that if you do anything
that kind of falls into this territory
if there's a way that you can make it
formal and recognized it's it's
worthwhile for your own documentation
for other people to support you just in
general
you